uh so good morning
thanks to the organizers for organizing
this conference and giving me the
opportunity to speak here
today i'll be telling you i'd like to
tell you about probabilistic programming
the
this
data analysis
tool and the
very readable code that
this this kind of methodology leads to
i'd also like to give you kind of a
firsthand account of how this field has
progressed over the last two decades
and it's been
an interesting and interesting ride i've
been going back and forth between
academia and
industry a few times
trying to connect you know the theory
from academia to
real problems and it's been interesting
so
i started my career
studying probability and math
i had this really great stats professor
and one of the first classes i took in
college and then had the opportunity to
join my master's advisor in a startup we
had and the entire startup was focused
on
bayesian modeling building probabilistic
models for aircraft tracking
so this that was around 2002 and around
2002 a probabilistic model usually meant
like a probabilistic graphical model
judea pearl and daphne kohler and kevin
murphy had popularized these uh these
probabilistic graphical models or
hierarchical bayesian models
multi-level probabilistic models they
all kind of mean similar things so let
me explain what these are in into detail
so
the idea here is that we have
uh probability distributions like here
there's a normal distribution and a log
normal distribution and we want to
connect those together to build a more
complex probabilistic model here we can
write uh
oops
here we can write like mu being sampled
from a normal
segment being sampled from log normal x
there's like a math notation on the left
and there's this uh you know visual
notation on the right
and crucially these probability
distributions are connected to each
other right we can draw these arrows
where the
upstream random variables can be used as
parameters of downstream random
variables
and we can
distinguish different types of random
variables there are these observed data
we can denote those as as shaded nodes
here
or hidden variables or latent variables
they're sometimes called are the things
you don't know in a model
okay
another motif that occurs quite often in
these these probabilistic models is
repeated
uh repeated nodes we might have i mean
we all have multiple we observe data
right we don't observe a data we have
multiple observations and that's a
little cumbersome to write here
but
people use this plate notation they draw
a box and they say how many times
something was repeated so it's a common
if it's a comment you know back in the
90s early 2000s it was a common way of
describing these these bigger models
um so let me explain how i or try to
explain why these these probabilistic
models are useful
i can't do
i can't i can't explain these any better
than andrew gilman so i'd recommend his
his great book but let me just briefly
mention some
advantages of these kinds of models
one is that in contrast you know this
this model you could have just computed
like the mean and the standard deviation
right why didn't we just um let mu be
the mean of the x's right and sigma v
the standard deviation why do we even
have a probabilistic model why don't we
just compute some moments here well one
reason is that we might not have much
data we might want to regularize our
computations and so we can add priors
here we can add prior knowledge and say
like if i only have one data point it's
really difficult to compute the standard
deviation but i'm going to want some
prior
to add some prior information if you
have a lot of data the prior gets washed
out it doesn't really matter but if we
have just a little bit of data it's
important to be able to add prior
knowledge for regularization
these models are useful i mean obviously
because because we can deal with noisy
data
here i've used a normal distribution but
but we might want different noise models
often we adjust the tail behavior we
instead of a normal distribution we will
use a heavy tail distribution to handle
outliers but we can really really
tightly calibrate
how we deal with with noisy data
this this framework of problems modeling
is is great for
fusing
different types of data for example here
we can make a slightly more complex
probabilistic model that
combines both
real value data and integer discrete
data that you observe right
in more generally these these models
give a consistent
semantic framework for fusing say like
image or text you know different types
different modalities of data in a clean
way
these these kinds of models define uh
the outputs of these models would be
like estimates of these parameters like
mu and sigma
and they output an uncertainty right
they can tell you if they don't know if
you don't have much data or if your data
doesn't tell you about a particular
variable they can these models can tell
you
hey i
you don't know
these these parameter estimates with
with very much certainty or some
parameters you might know with very high
certainty
in the bayesian framework we call that a
posterior distribution the prior is is
the distribution over data prior to
having any information seeing any any
observations and this posterior is
sorry the posterior distribution
is uh
the narrower typically narrower
distribution after seeing just post
scene data and we write this in this
funny notation p of mu comma sigma
given you know having seen this theta x
and y
and finally these are useful because
it's not just a single distribution
they're they're really composable you
know like like deep learning models you
can compose all these layers together
here you can compose all these
distributions together and you get you
can create really really complex uh
detailed models
so this is what we were building at my
advisor startup back in
2002 we had a he had an entire company
um based on you know using these
bayesian models for for uh aircraft
tracking
and this was you know 2002 in our
process this is um we weren't using
python back then we were writing uh a
lot of latex
um
we would write a model down in linktech
we would write an inference algorithm
in line check to infer things
we prototype the algorithm in matlab and
make sure it works and then we realize
it doesn't work and we change it and
then that doesn't work either and maybe
you know after some iterations it would
finally work and we tried to speed it up
in terms of asymptotics and then once
that was done we would we would
write a really high speed implementation
and optimize c plus plus right and this
took a long time months and months
and one of the forward-thinking software
engineers at this company back in 2002
suggested on a new project why don't we
try out this new thing this thing called
python this was before python 2 this was
this is like python
one um
and we were looking around for these
these you know there was there were
libraries in this um you know back in
when we used seatbelts plus we were
writing everything from scratch like
that you couldn't just import things you
couldn't install things in nc plus plus
everything was from scratch
and it was pretty cool in python because
there were these uh libraries like
numeric and numbered these were
predecessors of of numpy
and they were still not quite mature so
we ended up
not using uh these these libraries for
the project we ended up still writing c
plus because we were used to that but
then we would wrap it in in swig or
boost python
and that was a huge advancement right um
because we were in python there were you
know it was like an object-oriented
language it had a nice syntax it was
readable we could have really performed
low-level tools down low and then um
work with these work with these
abstractions in python and it was way
better than the you know the latex and
matlab workflow
and kevin murphy for example had also
been building these kind of modular
frameworks in matlab um python ended up
being nicer than matlab just because it
was a easier programming language to
work with
but this library that we built really
only worked with gaussians these
multi-dimen uh multivariate normal
distributions that represented like you
know where we thought an airplane was or
how fast it's going they were these
finite dimensional objects and it turns
out
aircraft tracking is kind of a
multi-multiple target tracking in
general is kind of the special
class of uh statistics problems
uh because you don't always know how
many aircraft there are
okay
often in statistics
you're trying to
infer some distribution over a vector
right it's a maybe it's a single
variable maybe it's like a 10
dimensional vector
in aircraft tracking you don't know the
length of the vector because you don't
know how many things you're trying to
track it's like if even if i was trying
to track people or something
you don't know exactly how many there
are right and this is this these are
called open world problems
and
they're
actually it's really difficult to do
this in this probabilistic graphical
model framework you can't have like an
unknown number of random variables it
just needs to be a fixed graph and so
people were thinking at the time like
how can we generalize this it's pretty
um it's pretty confining
um
we wanted to generalize these methods we
had this nice you know composable
framework for doing imprints but but we
couldn't
quite represent our entire problem we
could represent components of our
problem using these methods but not the
whole problem
and so
um
a lot of people at the time were
wondering like how could we how can we
generalize these things stuart russell
was doing research in kind of small
slight generalizations of graphical
models these open world modeling
languages um
but like
people were wondering how far could we
go like what's the most general
hypothesis space that you could you
could think of sometimes people call
these like non-parametric models but
i guess the most complex hypothesis base
would be a hypothesis based like the
things you're trying to infer right the
variables those hidden variables like
what's the most complicated random
variable
it's a program
because programs can do anything right
what if we could invert to bring you
know a program in some touring complete
language
and around that time
um abby pfeffer and norman ramsey um a
lot there are a lot of publications
around around that time you know
exploring this idea
here's here's a really interesting one
that started to connect uh
two two fields probabilistic modeling
and you know this machine learning
statistics on the one hand
and programming languages or like
computability on the other hand these
these two really different fields and it
was exciting to see this paper it was
talking about this this lambda calculus
that you know back in 2002 i had never
heard of this thing it was it was this
mysterious um
mysterious uh
you know concept from computer science
so here's a funny story
uh i was i was traveling in uh i was
traveling in camp to cambridge
massachusetts and visiting a friend i
was walking through a bookstore
and i came upon this
this uh
math book by uh the
dutch logician uh hank
on the lambda calculus and it was like
the lambie cows i don't know if you've
ever heard of building the calculus but
it you know if you've never heard of it
it sounds like some imposing thing i
didn't really know what it was i was
looking
you know reading this book standing
around literally in the bookstore
reading this book
and thinking like what what the heck do
all these symbols mean
but puzzling through it you know it
turns out this is you know this is a
weird looking formula here what does it
mean it turns out this is just uh
it's just like this lambda here it's
just like the same lambda that we use in
python right when we write an inline
function
it's just a lambda there and the
parentheses are kind of in the wrong
place for python but if you move the
parentheses over all this is saying is
you're applying a lambda function to
some argument n
and then the computer in that triangle
arrow thing is is executing that and
what do you get you get the function
body m with something substituted in
and what looked like you know at first
this arcane language
turned out to be it's just a programming
language right and back then i was a
programmer i thought hey i can do
programming languages it turns out this
is just a programming language this is
actually the first functional
programming language invented in
1931 by alonzo church this is like
before computers were around this is
this uh this lambda calculus
and i thought hey this is this is a this
is exactly what we need right we need
something like lambda calculus instead
of random variables right
we need um to infer things about
probabilistic programs or you know
really doing further things about
programs
so hank bar drake that the author here
had uh pasted continuing this funny
story hank barnvik had pasted some
photos of the researchers in the
sections in this book i was reading
and i was so excited i went and
contacted some of these uh these
researchers
and uh ended up
studying doing my phd spending four
years uh working with with
rick staffman and
um extending some research by dana scott
you know just out of this book just just
to uh learn more about the the lambda
calculus you know i studied all this
probability but it's really difficult to
you know
it was it was really difficult to deal
with these you know
touring complete kind of kind of
hypothesis spaces and so i figured why
don't i just spend a few years doing
that and then when i was in grad school
a lot of other people were thinking the
same thing they were thinking like why
don't we combine probabilistic modeling
with programming languages so in 2005
this this
really exciting paper came out
from
two groups frank frank fenning who is a
programming language researcher at
carnegie mellon i was actually thinking
of classifieds and sebastian through
who's
a roboticist right like the programming
languages and
robotics and machine learning and
kind of data science
fusing into this single paper it was
really exciting they were building a
probabilistic modeling language kind of
like the the graphical models we saw but
it was expressed in ocam functional
programming language and they were doing
inference over these opml programs and
they actually actually built this into a
robot that was that was um i think was
doing localization it was it was like a
real world problem
and then a few years later
uh
josh tenenbaum's lab at mit published
this paper on church which was like the
dream it was it was a
touring compete complete programming
language where you could infer
programs given given their outputs so it
was it was
really exciting
and noah goodman the first author of
this paper around this time coined this
phrase probabilistic programming
language
that really merged these two fields
so let me go back into detail i've been
talking about history a little bit but
um let's let's talk about what what does
this mean this probabilistic programming
language concept so remember we have
these two ways of viewing a
probabilistic model this is just a
really simple probabilistic model but
remember there's like the math view and
then there's a graphical model view
and then this new this new vision of
representing models as programs
uh exactly embeds this this these models
in
a programming language okay so here's
this is like a python
punch this is pseudocode
there are a lot of probabilistic
programming systems out there but none
of them look exactly like this but this
is pseudo code for what a model might
look like in a problem programming
language
and this is great because like these
these weird concepts of like you know
statisticians will write iid for for
independent identically distributed
variables and you know they draw those
as a box as a plate diagram well now we
can represent that as a for loop and
everyone knows what a for loop is it's
just so much more more tangible not only
that but we can represent you know this
for loop could have a length
that's a random variable that means we
can have like we can deal with open
world problems we can have dynamic
structure anything you can do in a
programming language you know if you
know conditional statements or recursion
we can now represent those as uh
distributions over program execution so
it really represented the uh
um
this full vision of being able to infer
over over
complex you know unknown dimensional
spaces not just euclidean space that you
know statisticians i dealt with in the
20th century
so let's let's look at this model code
just in a little more detail
this model code has
some latent variables and some observed
variables the latent variables we're
going to
represent those as samples
using a sample primitive and this isn't
quite a
function um it's better to think of this
as like a keyword or a special like a
new special kind of control flow
construct
um as like extending into a new language
and similarly the observations the
likelihood here we can introduce those
as as like a new keyword an observed
keyword and again it's better to think
of these as uh two kind of magical
primitives that we're extending the
language with okay
in fact python is so dynamic that you
can do anything in python and in fact
in practice we can represent these with
functions but they have special meaning
and i think it's it's clear to think of
them as an extension of the language
but that's not all you need to represent
uh you know a probabilistic program one
of these probabilistic models you need
something else that's a little more
subtle and that's some sort of inference
run time you can't run these models like
scripts like
when we write when we run python
functions right we run them in the
python runtime and they execute right
you can't do that with probabilistic
programs you can't use this standard
python runtime and that's why it's a
really different concept that's why we
call it a probabilistic programming
language it's not just like a library
it's an entire new like programming
language with its own runtime and this
runtime here i call it infer posterior
but that that's just made up it's the
idea of the runtime though is that it's
a solver it's an inference algorithm
it's a machine learning algorithm
and this is a really subtle concept so i
want to
try to make an analogy with something
else you might be familiar with
so you remember back in
studying math you studied you know some
at some point you studied arithmetic you
learn to
you know add numbers and subtract
numbers and multiply numbers and divide
numbers
and in arithmetic you're given some
numbers and an expression and you
evaluate it forward right and you end up
what's whether you end up at the end
with you end up with a number okay
later on you studied algebra okay in
algebra
it was a little bit different in algebra
you're given an equation or a group of
equations
and you don't execute the equations
right you have to reason backwards the
equations have unknowns in them okay
and when you you know when you're being
an algebraicist you have to think about
what what could this have been what
could these missing variables have been
right and you use inference machinery
like the quadratic formula you can think
of that as an algorithm right
you you have a an equation
you have this algorithm that's like the
quadratic formula and it says here's
what the missing variable could be could
it could have been and sometimes there
are two answers there could be multiple
answers though but but the point is in
algebra you're not running things
forward you're running them you're kind
of
inferring what could have happened okay
running them kind of backwards
let's let's let's think it back in terms
of probabilistic programming when we can
think of scripting you know typical you
know
data processing we all write data
processing scripts you can think of that
as kind of like arithmetic
you're running something forward you're
running a script forward and you end up
with with some data at the end but when
we write a probabilistic program it's
closer to algebra here we have it's kind
of equate and
we have kind of an equation right
and what we want is to solve for this mu
and sigma
okay it's in this inference algorithm
it's it's not quite the quadratic
formula but it's something similar it's
like a technique we can use to figure
out what those hidden variables could
have been
okay
and typically the way these uh
infants algorithms work is they return
some distribution
because this is it's not like algebra
where there's a single solution or a set
of solutions here we're in statistics
land right probability land and here we
want to think about probability of
distributions over things so so the
solution to our algebra you know
equation here is a distribution over the
mu and sigma
okay um and these inferences these
inference runtimes the result notice
there's no return statement in this
model right we're not like running
forward and getting something out we're
solving
this model for what the mu and sigma
could have been
and the solution is a posterior
distribution a distribution over what
the values could have been
a lot of inference runtimes simply
return a set of samples
it's difficult like there's no universal
representation for a probability
distribution over over
multiple random variables like maybe
maybe it's a multivariate normal but
maybe it's not maybe it's some weird
distribution but you can always draw
samples from it and that's like a kind
of universal interchange format so a lot
of these
inference algorithms will return a set
of like 100 samples or a thousand
samples you can do whatever you want
with those you can compute the mean or
the median or some quantiles and get get
confidence intervals or credible
integrals but it's a nice kind of output
so where is this a script might output
like a file or some number
inference algorithms offer return a set
of samples
okay so so
so far we've seen that these
probabilistic programs are kind of a new
way of
they're different from just normal
python it's kind of a new way of running
programs okay
and you may have heard of conway's law
you know conway's law says that
software code bases grow to reflect
their you know the organizations that
create them i think that that's often
true when i see you know even the
company i work for i see code bases
where
it's clear
that two people don't talk to each other
because they're code bases that don't
talk to each other
here
we've organized our code
into two distinct kind of areas right
there's models
and there's some low-level inference
algorithms okay
and this allows a particular kind of
organizational structure
okay
these models are should be easy to read
and they're they're they capture facts
about the world and so kind of everybody
should be looking at these things
scientists should be looking and domain
experts should be looking at those right
whereas these inference algorithms
it's it's they're kind of
you know they take a lot of work but
they're kind of easy it's clear what
what's correct
and it's clear they need to be fast
right
you can just put some engineers on that
hey here's some unit tests
make sure that you know here's some
benchmarking suites you know go do it
and you can go you know hang out in your
your your dark
room and just code these for hours and
hours you don't really need to talk to
anyone right so it's a it's a nice way
like organizationally a factoring code
into code that everyone needs to look at
and code that you can go off in the
corner and just like get it right it's
clear what what what's correct
so i really like this this factorization
of code
so
after grad school uh you know i was
really sold on this idea this idea of
probabilistic programming um
after grad school i i ended up joining
another uh aircraft tracking company my
job talked there was like a
probabilistic models are great but
probabilistic programming is the future
you know
it was it was clear that this was this
was where things were going
and i ended up working working around
for a few different companies and some
startups and some big companies working
on machine learning platforms at some
big companies
but you know over the years i never i
never really productionized a
probabilistic programming system it was
you know this dream and it remained a
dream i think for for a lot of years
um
a long time later uh i met this this guy
perry developed sorry these names aren't
legible perry developed at uh who's an
entomology professor
like an ecologist at uh uc berkeley
and he he you know in industry it was
really tough to find people who believed
in the separation of models and
inference right as an ideology you know
in industry
you got to get things done and it's
tough to get things done when you're
bound to an ideology but
it's also nice to follow an ideology and
i ended up joining uh period of
alphine's group there
to work on his his probabilistic
modeling system uh it's called nimble
and it has a very clean front end it's
an r it has it's an r library with a c
plus plus back end
and our the r front end is very clean
and the c plus plus back end is very
fast
and not very clean but no one has to
look at it because it's fast and there's
some tests
and it's a really beautiful
factorization of code
one issue though with the system is we
were using is the type of in the out the
particular inference algorithm we were
we were using and that's uh markov chain
monte carlo
and uh mark marcotte chain monte carlo
algorithms
are
pretty slow um
and especially they don't they don't
scale with dimension
at the time
uh this is 2017 and so
2015 tensorflow had been released and
provided a really nice gpu framework and
so we had this idea of this project
where we would integrate
uh tensorflow you know try to try to use
tensorflow and the gpu computations to
speed up this nimble programming
language
and so we spent a few months on that um
and it was it was pretty crazy we had we
had you know tensorflows in python r was
in uh r nimbles and r and so we had this
like r code talking to python code
talking to c postcode and then we had a
seatpost post backhand that would
directly talk to tensorflow see those
backend and
it was it was
quite a mess and wasn't super fast
but then i heard through a friend
that uh zubin barmani and
noah goodman at uber
were building a probabilistic
programming language from scratch
pytorch had just released been released
this is 2017. i think uh earlier earlier
that year pytorch had just been released
by facebook
and uh noah goodman who is that same
first author who coined the phrase
probabilistic programming language he
was working on a new probabilistic
programming language that's built on pi
torch okay and so this sounded great you
know
we had these slow inference algorithms
but these these fast new deep learning
libraries why don't we build something
from scratch
so i ended up joining uh
noah's group to build this this
pyro probabilistic programming language
and led development um on that
but let me let me try to explain in a
little more detail why this was a really
exciting idea to to combine
probabilistic programming languages with
these deep learning frameworks okay
so at this at this point
neural networks have been around for a
long time right jeff hinton had been
working on those since
the early 80s i think
and they didn't really have huge success
until the early 2000s right and i think
there were some new architectures but
but a lot of the success was due to
things that weren't really specific to
neural networks at all so
uh like like jeff hinden and yama-kun
adopted these great engineering
practices like they made all their their
neural networks run on gpus and gpus
were you know they had a lot of compute
power and
they were shaped pretty well for neural
networks which meant that these neural
networks could have could train on many
more parameters
they used stochastic optimization
algorithms like
stochastic gradient descent and these
algorithms permitted mini batching so
previously a lot of algorithms would
have to train on the entire data set
every every epic like every step
but
these mini batch algorithms allow you to
have you know unboundedly much data
because you only needed to look at just
a little bit of data every every every
step
automatic differentiation libraries were
becoming easier to use automatic
differentiation had been around for a
long time there were four fortran ad
algorithms but they were
libraries but they were difficult to use
and then i don't know around this around
this time 2010s these automatic
differentiation algorithms
were becoming easier to use and saving
people time i think early in my career i
spent months you know hand deriving
gradients a lot of machine learning
researchers with hand derived gradients
and it just you know it's it's a waste
of time
you know it's it's awful to have derived
gradients when you could instead use a
library so that's it people a lot of
time and admit that their design cycles
could be shorter and they ended up with
better better results and finally
something that's not often talked about
is like
the advance of
software engineering and these libraries
really coming together like tensorflow
really having good software engineering
practices good good tests and
documentation
good good open source practices
and that really led to some advancements
meanwhile probabilistic programming as a
field was still kind of languishing they
were you know there were some people
applying mcmc
putting mcmt algorithms on gpus
but it really hadn't caught up um in
terms in terms of
you know its parallel progress to deep
learning
but around the mid 2010s there were some
interesting papers that showed how these
deep learning approaches could be
applied to probabilistic programming and
probably the most exciting paper was to
drink king mike swelling's paper
on introducing variational auto encoders
we had used you may have heard the dvds
before we talked about vaes let me
explain what an auto encoder is though
so an auto
is just a particular
architecture for a neural network
it consists of
an encoder that's the the green thing is
the encoder that takes like an image for
example and encodes it into an embedding
okay like a like a low dimensional
embedding vector
and then the blue thing is a neural
network that decodes that in back into
an image okay the idea is that we want
to do dimensionality reduction
we train one of these neural networks we
train both of those neural networks at
once
such that the reconstruction we train it
on reconstruction loss to make sure that
we can compress something and decompress
it and the reconstructed thing is
accurate
okay and these have been around for for
a while but this time
so kingman welling's insight was that
if you squint and add a little bit of
noise to this auto encoder
it actually looks like a probabilistic
model
and you can train it using a variational
loss
that's that's why they call this a
variational auto encoder
that was really exciting because
the
the variational perspective turned this
what looked like just a just a neural
network into a probabilistic model okay
here often probabilistic model you know
probabilistic programming language land
we have been looking around for for
really fast uh inference algorithms and
here's a way of looking at an algorithm
you know the
deep learning auto encoder algorithm
tweaking things a little bit and then it
allowed us to
import that algorithm idea
into the into the land of probability
probabilistic modeling
in fact we could split up
this
autoencoder this variational auto
encoder
into two parts to the uh the decoder and
the encoder and we can think of these
two parts as a generative model and an
inference model which which is kind of
part of the inference algorithm
so a few research researchers at that
time
realized in the probabilistic
programming field realized that
this this vae pattern
the variational autoencoder idea
might be used
to define more general models like what
if we replaced
those encoder network and decoder
network with structured things
structured things like probabilistic
models right or probabilistic programs
so here's this recipe i don't want to
get too much into the details of this
recipe
but the idea is that
kingman welling had
imported this recipe
you know from from deep learning
um
that could be reused across models they
did that this this i think this training
regimen for for variational auto
encoders didn't depend on the network
architecture at all right you can plug
you can plug in any sort of network
architecture for those encoder decoder
in fact you could plug in
um
structured things
and this didn't uh you know this this
training
algorithm didn't change at all
and that was exciting for people like uh
david bly and
justin tran and noah goodman because
that meant they could implement it once
in a library
and then uh build a really flexible
front end for defining uh these these
models these these components that we
want to train
so just one more one area of looking at
that is that
the decoder network here can be thought
of as a probabilistic model
and the encoder network can be thought
of as part of an inference algorithm so
when we implemented this this um this is
the whole idea behind pyro um the pyro
progressive programming language and
edward which was dustin
which is dust and trans probabilistic
programming language
the whole idea is is to um use this va
like like uh training approach to to fit
probabilistic models and perform
inference and it scales way better than
you know these old mcmc algorithms
scaled
also this
one requirement here is that you
actually need to write that inference
model and so some of the work we did in
power was to automate that part so that
all you need to do is really pay
attention to the smaller front end
so that's what that's what we built in
that that's what we built into pyro this
this uh
probabilistic programming language out
of uber ai labs we open sourced this in
2017 and it got way more
um
attraction and and contribution than we
expected it was adopted by the linux
foundation in 2019 and it was
interesting
to see some of the follow-up papers
people who built on top of this remember
there's this kind of separation between
modeling and inference and we really saw
the people who were building on top of
this some of them were like the
inference engineer inference researcher
kind of people and they would write
machine learning methods papers
and there were a lot of people who just
used pyro on the modeling side and would
import you know their our standard
inference algorithms and just build
science on top of this
so for the rest of this talk i'd just
like to
talk about uh some particular
applications that people have built on
top of pyro
um
so
actually one of the really surprising
things we were using pyro
uh here let me back up for a minute
so so inside inside uber we were using
pyro for a future thing so we're using
it for
some causal inference from some time
series forecasting
um and for some data fusion we had we
had a maps project at one point that was
like a competitor to google maps and we
were fusing all sorts of different data
um in this maps project and these
bayesian models are really scalable and
good for for data fusion
one really surprising thing for us
though was was how many of these people
who were using pyro were actually in the
biosciences and genetics so unbeknownst
to us there was um this explosion of uh
genetics research
i i come from more of like a math and
computer science background and i was
really excited like many of you may have
been involved like moore's law because
you know if you study computer science
then uh
you know three years from now you'll get
what four times as much compute power
right every every everything is is
growing right in uh in computer science
it's growing by this this well-known
moore's law
it turns out genetics
genetic sequencing technology is growing
faster than moore's law it's a super
exciting field
and
all of the applications i'm going to
tell you about are in genetics and
biology so
this is a this is some research i'm not
this is not my research at all this is
research by
vitaly
klush chugnikov and some other people
who who were using pyro to
single cell rna sequencing analysis so
this is a transcriptomics
project where
they're trying to infer where cells are
located
in tissue and they're doing this by
individually sequencing every cell so
maybe you know
back 10
20 years ago
it was a it was a feat to sequence a
genome okay
these days you can sequence every cell
and you can sequence tens of thousands
of cells each cell in in
in a large scale sequencing experiment
and it leads to this huge profusion of
data that it's really difficult to
analyze with classical statistics but
these you know scalable variational
inference methods ended up being really
good for these approaches uh but talia
built this
research on top of pyro and he ended up
contributing some great uh great code
back to the pyro system that is
available for everyone now
another
application we saw was
by mayor tosh babadi who's a researcher
at the broad institute in cambridge
um and
this research tried to distinguish he
built this probabilistic model this is
like one of those graphical models
here's a picture of his graphical model
that he built with this project and he
was trying to distinguish in a large
experiment
uh kind of
uh
rna sequences that came from cells
versus rna sequences that came from junk
that was floating around in the solution
and he was using variational inference
for this um i'm not going to get into
any details here but ritosh was also
really excited about building these
scalable variational inference
algorithms and analyzing lots of data
um
and he actually um
we met
uh my team met the natasha probably
programming conference and
he was so compelling in his in his his
tales of of you know this
steeper than moore's law and growth of
the field that a few of us ended up
joining the montage we ended up moving
to the broad institute to work with
vertosh and work on genetics problems
and so now now i work in the field of
biology
and
the next
okay and the final application i want to
tell you about is in more detail i'll go
into some actual details here rather
than just
glossing over so mark miamiak and i
were some of the
pyro team at uh uber and we
after having met maritosh we joined the
broad institute this was during
2020 during the first
months of the pandemic
and then the pandemic at that time was
on everybody's mind
and so we decided to you know we had
this great opportunity to work with with
world-class epidemiologists and
biologists including parties sibetti's
lab at harvard and jeremy lupin's lab at
university of massachusetts so
here we worked on a project
on
stars kobe 2
sequencing and
forecasting
so let me go into the details of this
project
a lot of people have been looking at
the genomics of tsar's kobe 2. so
one thing that that was different in
this this panoramic than any other
pandemic is that people were sequencing
the virus okay
we have
millions now of genetic sequences of
different virus particles complete
complete genomes of these particles
here's a phylogenetic tree and each leaf
on this phylogenetic tree is a is a
sargasso v2 sample that's been
completely genetically sequenced
up until up until this point the
phylogenetic analysis tools which are
not most of them are bayesian and very
probabilistic these phylogenetic
analysis tools have been able to handle
maybe ten thousand
uh ten thousand sequences they could
scale up to ten thousand sequences and
that was a lot of sequences in 2015 and
that was like no one had more than ten
thousand sequences of anything you know
any of these viruses right
during the pandemic though we had this
you know again faster than moore's law
growth of data when we started this
project there were there were seventy
thousand i think we had we started
looking at seventy thousand sequences
and so we were thinking oh why don't we
just write some you know faster
phylogenetic analysis tools we'll just
scale up to
a hundred thousand instead of seventy
thousand right or instead of ten
thousand which which is like the scale
of the original um
tools and even while we were doing this
you know
it's like we were being inundated in the
water you know we're up to our neck and
data
um six months into this project there
were there were like millions of samples
and even even our early efforts were
um
we're failing to to uh look at
trees like these phylogenetic trees so
we step back and thought hey we need we
really need a scalable method here so
instead we looked at aggregate
statistics and so the aggregate
statistics instead of that fancy tree
that has very fine resolution we decided
to just look at aggregate statistics
the aggregate statistics we want to look
at were the relative strain proportions
and i'll use the word strain as the same
as variant or lineage it's just like a a
group of services but we do you've
probably heard of delta or omicron or
alpha or b117 or all these different
names we can think of those as different
kinds of service kobe 2. okay and over
time
there's been different portions in any
population right
so this is what we tried to model
and
the way we wanted to model this was with
just a simple regression model a
logistic growth regression model fitting
sigmoid curves to our observed data okay
and sigmoid curves are nice because
they they sum to one one way of looking
at a sigmoid curve
is as a multiple linear regression you
fit two lines and then map those through
a soft max function
okay that's you know the soft max is uh
you know one over one plus e to the
negative something
um
this isn't the only way to define a
logistic growth
uh curve
but this is a nice way to this this is
this
you know defining it in terms of max is
nice because it it very easily
generalizes to multivariate logistic
growth okay so we can think of a
multivariate logistic function as having
multiple lines and like hey we can all
do linear regression all we need to do
is linear regression then map it through
a softmax function and then we get out
we can look at this
sorry we can look at this in in two
different ways we can look at like each
of the individual concentrations or we
can look at that stack plot like we saw
in a couple slides back in the stack
plot of the different different
proportions
so we fit one of these multivariate you
know multiple strain logistic growth
curves to a little bit of data we just
look at england's data during the early
kind of england has
great geneticists and a great genetic
sequencing infrastructure and they since
the very beginning of the pandemic had
collected a lot of data and so we could
use them as like a test
region
and we fit a multivariate logistic curve
to their data and it looks like it's a
beautiful fit right
these each of these curves each of these
curves has only two parameters right
they're then mapped to the softmax
function but it's like for a two
parameter curve that's that's a pretty
good fit we were really excited about
that
but we had you know england is just one
of the locations around the world
these genetic sequences were being
collected around the world and there was
a world full of data a lot of people at
the time had been using you know already
using these logistic growth curves but
they've been looking at like one or two
strains at a time and maybe looking at
their home with their local city or
their local country
but we decided why don't we model all of
the data
why don't we just look at everything
um
those people weren't looking at
everything because there were no tools
to look at everything so we thought how
can we look at everything
so we decided what
why don't we just put all of the data
into a cube we'll make we'll we'll have
a cube that has all of the regions
and all of the the time spans like we'll
bend it into leak and we'll have all of
the streams we'll
split up
that phytogenetic tree into a
thousand or fifteen hundred different
strains or variants right this is a huge
cube this is uh or a rectangular
whatever you call it
it has like 200
mil i think this is like 200 million
different buckets but it's sparse so
that's it's actually pretty cheap we can
actually um
represent this on
gpu pretty cheaply
and to model this we build just one of
these multi-level regression models like
a republican bayesian model there's
actually no dynamic control flow here
it's just like a pretty vanilla
probabilistic graphical model
thing is we can run it on enormous data
there's half a million hidden variables
here inside these plates here remember
we saw those plate diagrams earlier in
the talk here there's overlapping plates
and that's like nested for loops and
every time you have a nested floor loop
you have like quadratic growth of the
things inside there right because
so each of these this s plate and p
plate are pretty big they have like a
thousand things in them so we ended up
with a half a million hidden variables
and that's a that's uh a lot of
it's a lot of hidden variables there um
i mean we built a joint model
to infer these things
but this ran on you know this ran on our
deep probabilistic programming framework
on a gpu
and we could we could perform inference
in uh
about 10 minutes which was amazing
for the first time we you know performed
inference we got garbage and the tenth
time we performed inference we got
garbage but maybe by the 15th time twist
you know tweaking the model filtering
the data
we had some pretty good results the only
way we could get to the 50th time of
training this model though is by having
a model that trained really quickly
right we need a lot of iteration
another really cool thing about this
model was that we really did follow you
know this this ideology of having
modeling and inference code
the model was really clean and and
had this really short code right
now don't misunderstand me there was
tons of gross code in this project that
you can go look at the repo there's tons
of gross data punching code thousands of
lines of data munching code thousands of
lines of evaluation and validation code
but no one really needs to look at that
you know maybe get a little bit of code
review on some of that
what people really need to pay attention
to when we had these big zoom meetings
with a dozen scientists all looking at
you know a model they're looking at just
a tiny bit of code and there's a lot of
opinions of those zoomed meetings and
there's a lot of arguments and people
saying like you know this this doesn't
seem quite right and i don't think this
is you know this makes physical sense
and i like i'm i'm just
um i'm just a
kind of a
you know a machine learning researcher i
don't know how these things are supposed
to work
but it was really great to have all
these you know epidemiologists and
virologists in on the call and really
focusing our attention on the things
that are scientifically important
on one of those calls uh jacob lemieux
this this uh epidemiologist at mass
general hospital had this brilliant idea
of making a slight change to this model
so originally we've been doing some
forecasting we were forecasting forward
and seeing like what are this what are
the strain proportions
he thought like hey what if we change
the model a little bit and regress
against the mutations we know how the
genetic sequence is what if we try to
fit these growth rates against the
mutations that we observe
it's a slight change to the model like
look at this three three or four lines
have changed it's a slight change
but it's it's it's like a totally
different model
we used to you know we started out we
set out to uh
do time series forecasting and we ended
up with what's called a genome-wide
association study which is which is a
totally different kind of
result so let me try to explain this
picture i don't i only have a few
minutes left but let me try to explain
this picture so
this is the final result of a
genome-wide association study it's
called the manhattan plot because
sometimes it looks like a manhattan
skyline
along the x-axis we have the sars kofi
genome it's about 30 000 nucleotides
long okay
each of the dots
is a mutation that's been observed in
the wild
along the y-axis
we plot each dot the height at which we
plot each dot each mutation
is our model's prediction for how much
that mutation
increases the fitness
of sardis pogi2
okay
how can we do that we regress the slope
the fitness right on those logistic
curves the slope is like the fitness if
we have two strains of starch but v2 and
they have different slopes
the difference in those slopes is like
the relative fitness
okay
if we regress those numbers against
mutation we can see which parts of the
genome are evolving right i never would
have thought about this you know it was
only because jacob lemoo had this
brilliant idea that we could get to this
point but it the results ended up being
very very uh credible
a lot of the fitness
increasing genes
mutations including the spike gene
um
there were some surprises where there
are these non-structured proteins that
seem to be increasing fitness and people
hadn't been studying this almost
everyone was focusing on the spike gene
the most surprising thing was that there
was this super high spike in the
nucleocapsid protein
in one really tiny region of the
nucleocapsid protein right this is a
totally
i don't know
surprising scientific result and it was
actually just just like just after we uh
published our preprint this was
corroborated by jennifer bagnes team
they did some somewhat like experiments
to uh to do this
um
i'll end there but i just i just want to
say that that was that was a really fun
project that i that i got to do with uh
party subsidies lab and
jacob
and it really it really showed how you
know this ideology of having common code
that everything this declarative model
could lead to a really great
collaboration and i continue to
collaborate with people i work at this
this protein startup generate
biomedicines
and i continue to collaborate with with
uh scientists they're using using this
paradigm and the world is i guess it's a
final one the world is great what a
great time to be alive there's so many
problems that programming libraries
available now there's plenty of
literature out there if you're
interested in reading about these
[Applause]
any questions
maybe i should ask a question first of
all thank you for your interesting
speech so um
it's interesting to hear your
insight of
how you see
how will the probabilistic programming
feel develop further in the future and
what
further applications it will have
yeah that's a that's a really good
question um
i would say i would say
right now
it's it's
really easy to work with these
kind of old-school probabilistic
graphical models these and especially if
they have continuous random variables
that's kind of a solved problem
we can do that like in this last
application
it's a little more difficult if
you have
say discrete random variables in the
middle of your model
that makes inference a little more
difficult if there's dynamic structure
so remember there's this vision of
inferring the world as represented by
you know a program in some truly
complete language we're not there what
we can do is construct like
a smaller hypothesis space a limited set
of programs and maybe some programs that
have fixed structure and a few
parameters especially continuous
parameters and we can solve that right
it's more difficult if there's dynamic
program structure it's more difficult if
there are discrete random variables and
there's
uh
there's some techniques but it still
takes a lot of a lot of work to get that
to work i think in the future
it would really be great if if we could
expand the class of programs that could
that can serve as our kind of random
variables you know if we think of
random variable as program
it would be great if we could say
think of a python program of 100 lines
right that's all you know there's a
there's a 100 line python program and
that's your random variable figure it
out what it is right
that's like the dream we're
definitely not there but we can inch
towards it and i think we'll we'll
slowly pinch towards that
in in the future as for applications um
i i really think biology is a really
exciting field there's there's um
amazing new
experimental assays being developed so
those so these probabilistic models are
really great at handling noisy data
sparse data extremely noisy data large
large amounts of it
and i think some of the most exciting
work right now is in
new experimental assays in biology
that's the field i've chosen to to join
and make progress in
and i think those that's that'll be a
place where there are a lot of new
applications for these scalable
um
entrance algorithms
yes
yes so what do you think about
connections between probabilistic
programming languages and quantum
community
wow the connections between
probabilistic programming languages and
quantum computing
i've heard that
quantum computing can can speed up a lot
of computations
it might be that
quantum computing could speed up some of
the computations that occur in
probabilistic programming
i think it remains to be seen
um
i think i think it remains to be seen
how that will work out i'm interested in
probabilistic you know quantum computing
also because
a lot of the
a lot of the questions we ask it that
generate viral medicines are about how
things that are actually quantum behave
and so
you know there's this idea of general
quantum computing but even specifically
quantum computing to simulate quantum
systems might be more exciting than
quantum computing to simulate things
that
you know maybe you could run on a
cluster so
it's i don't know how to answer that
thoughts sorry i have a question
um
yeah maybe the 19th start
uh well thank you first of all thank you
for the
nice presentation and the uh speech
uh and i have a question concerning the
models did you say that you were able to
see
how
was able to predict
which limitations evolved in the end in
real life something for the last several
months for example
so it couldn't
this this research could
predict
among mutations that have been observed
how they have affected it was very much
retrospective
research how they have affected growth
rate
we had no
model
of like a predictive model of how
novel mutations might in the future
affect growth rate that would be the
domain of something that maybe had
molecular models molecular simulations
and other people are building models
like that and there's some even there's
some interesting work out of debbie
marx's lab at harvard
about looking at not just uh stars coke
two but all cervical viruses
and trying to use statistics there to to
determine what what new novel mutations
might um
might affect growth rate uh i think i
think that
the most important interesting result of
this research wasn't even the individual
mutations but but isolating regions of
the genome
where we're seeing rapid evolution and
those are reasons that
regions where
researchers might in the future want to
spend more more effort
on doing experiments
there's a question in the middle do you
want to
if you want to just uh see your question
well here yeah well
the microphone was gave to me so yeah uh
thank you for presentation it was really
great and uh my question about the
productive so sorry beforehand
so why probabilistic programming and
nuts
and neural networks
or in other words could please provide
some pros and cons why not both i
wouldn't get a model you know right
right now with some colleagues where we
have a policy program that's very
interpretable and in the middle of that
you squash the neural network which
isn't quite interpretable about it but
it fits the data really well like
there's you don't need to choose our you
know our people has built you know pyro
was built on top of pie torch and you
can put pyro models inside your pie
torch models and you can put fiber
models inside your pyro models um one
one reason to choose you know you know
you could do both but but one reason to
choose a probabilistic model and is in
particular because those latent
variables are interpretable
and there's a lot of work trying to
interpret the inners of neural networks
but
in problems of program we start with
interpretability right everything is
interpretable from the outset there's no
there's no ambiguity you know what you
know that half million variables we had
in the middle of our
our growth model every one of those is
completely interpretable so
i guess if you want things to be
interpretable you could you could even
select
in a large and a large model you could
even select
the things you want to be interpretable
and use problems to programming for that
and the things you don't really care
about you just want really good accuracy
you can have that be black box neural
neural layers
all right thank you very much but sorry
you have a question in the middle and
i'm sorry i've been you've been you keep
getting delayed
oh here's here comes the microphone
okay so first of all thank you very much
for the talk it was really interesting
and i actually had pretty much the same
question because i recall from in the
past i used our nimble and saw that
there was a lot of friction in people
adopting probabilistic models because of
the computational expense and it seems
that
there's been a way to overcome a lot of
this and not require the use of monte
carlo sampling for example but then it
seems that still there is quite a bit of
friction that people are not
so willing to adopt probabilistic
modeling and so
um you said that we can do both but
where do you think uh the friction still
remains is it in selecting prior
distributions for example is it in
people trusting these models like why
isn't everybody using probabilistic
modeling
um yeah that's a good that's a good
question
i think i think
you probably answered the question in
that it used to be that that uh
inference was very slow
uh these he's just
um
mcmc can be very slow there's there's
been progress there's progress being
made in mcmc
but i tend to use variational infrared
stochastic variational inference
stochastic gradient variational entrance
and that's very fast it's not as
accurate as mcmc but
it's it's much much faster it scales
much better and i find that
given a choice between
high high accuracy inference that's slow
or
slightly lower accuracy inference that's
fast it's better to
to
use fast cheap inference because then
you can iterate on your model you can
train a model and realize look i could
have done perfect inference on the wrong
model but if i do pretty good inference
i can see that the model is wrong and i
can change the model and i think that
kind of workflow of using faster
slightly less accurate inference and
then really iterating quickly on the
model is is um
i think that'll help people use
probabilistic models more
another answer to your question though
is i think really in terms of
interpretability the places where i most
see probabilistic models
being used are where
people really
really want to interpret everything
about the model when they're
literally when there are you know five
scientists in on a call if
there are five scientists in on a call
they want to argue about
what's semantically correct and
if they have a semantically meaningful
model that they can argue about you know
we can come to consensus about about
what what the right model is that's
really difficult to do with uh with a
black box machine learning model right
you can't argue about what the
architecture needs to be you need to you
know do architecture search and then and
then you can do cross-validation
experiments but there's nothing really
for for scientists to argue about right
there's no room for for you know years
of expertise to be baked into those
priors right and i work with a lot of
scientists
and there's a huge amount of knowledge
that that they have and
it's difficult to make that knowledge
into a
a deep learning model whereas it's
much easier to break those in as priors
to take advantage of the experts you
know if we have the opportunity to
collaborate in the next place
thank you for the interesting talk um
you probably already answered my
question in your prior answer but what
i'm to ask you is what are the pros and
cons
within the approach you applied at mcmc
so in the process of constant product
caused between the approach you've
applied the version approach and the
mcmc approach
oh um
yeah
so i i often use variational inference
which which is a
a very fast but approximate entrance
method
um
if if you can it's
it's more accurate if you have the time
it's more accurate to
use mcmc because of generally markup
gene monitor because it generally
provides more accurate answers
along with along with pyro so in pyro we
usually use variational inference but
there's a
following there's like a sister project
called none pyro which is based on
google's jacks back end
and jax
does some really smart
program analysis
to make mcmc very fast in jax and so a
lot of people actually um
use mcmc and numpyro for small models
sometimes i'll
one cool thing about about
probabilistic programming is that you
can write the model and then apply
different
inference algorithms to it right you can
have one piece of code that's the model
and i often do that even in that in that
star spoken two project
um i started out with
a model and then a variational inference
method and an mcm seems infinite and the
variational reference method took like
10 to 15 minutes at first
and the mcmc method took five hours
and it was
a little bit more accurate
but the model was wrong and so i don't
know i i still feel like uh
there's there's more to be there's more
to be gained in finding a better model
than there is to be having um you know
doing perfect inference
[Applause]